انا اشوف شخصيا حضاره ما اخذت حقها من
التاريخ عندك مملكه قدار مملكه قدار
لما كانت دائما بحروب مع الاشورين
والبابليين بعد انتصار الملك سلمان نصر
الثالث على مملكه قيدار لما الوثق
الانتصار كتب الملك جنديب وملك العرب وهذا
اقدم واول ذكر لكلمه عرب
فملكه قدار شعبها كانوا طبيعه حياتهم الى
الى حياتنا اليوميه للان يعني البدو كانت
قبائل لها الشيخ يحكمها بعدين تطورت اصبحت
مملكه والحكم وراثي في عندك ملكات عربيات
مثل ملكه زبيبه الملكه شمسي كلهم اداروا
مملكه قدار اللي عاصمتها الان دومه الجندل
كان اسمها دوماتو اللي هي فيها قلعه مارد
وهي تابعه لمملكه قدار بس صار في استيطان
للحضارات كثيره مثل الفتره الاسلاميه
والانباط وغيرها فكانت الحروب مع
الاشوريين كانت بسبب طرق التجاره لانها
تشق الى سوريا وتم العثور مثلا في مصر على
اواني تابعه
الملك مملكه قدار لكن وين الاواني مثلا
ممكن اسالك او المخلفات الاثريه اللي في
دومه الجندل هي عاصمتهم يعني ما نعرف مثلا
دائما يقول لك المنتصر يكتب التاريخ فكل
اللي نعرفه عن مملكه قيذار بناء على
النقوش الاشوريه اللي ذكرت مملكه قدار لكن
بالضبط وهذه الاشياء اللي يذكرها المنتزه
طبعا لا شك ان الاشوريين يعني حضاره كانت
الاقوى يعني في وقتها وكل شيء لكن وين
ممكن نقول مملكه قدار شعبها يحكي عن نفسه
فهذا اكيد انه موجود